bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat à suivre ce
matin en séance l'examen de la réforme
électorale annoncée par François
Hollande lors des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale cette réforme
modifie le calendrier électoral ainsi
que le mode d'élection des conseillers
municipaux et départementaux et des les
délégués communautaires le texte prévoit
notamment un nouveau mode de scrutin le
scrutin binominal paritaire qui devrait
entrer en vigueur pour la toute première
fois si le texte est adopté lors des
prochaines élections cantonales en 2015
cette innovation permettra d'inscrire
deux conseillers un homme et une femme
par canton mais simultanément elle
imposera un redécoupage des cantons car
deux élus par circonscription imposent
de réduire leur nombre par par deux et
c'est précisément ce dernier point le
redécoupage des cantons qui inquiète
l'opposition car c'est le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui décidera seul par arrêté
de ce redécoupage le Parlement n'aura
donc pas son mot à dire résultat le
groupe UMP du Sénat s'inquiète que le
nombre des élus des zones rurales soit
divisé par deux ou par trois au profit
des agglomérations autre inquiétude pour
l'opposition l'abaissement du score de
12,5 % à à 10 % des inscrits permettant
d'accéder au second tour pour
Jean-Claude Godin le président du groupe
UMP du Sénat c'est la certitude qu'il y
aura davantage de triangulaire au avec
le Front national tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle pour l'examen de
ce projet très bonne matinée à tous sur
Public
Sénat monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la séance est reprise l'ordre
du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion générale commune sur les deux
textes qui sont en qui sont en
discussion et dans la suite de la
discussion générale commune la parole
est à Monsieur Pierre Camani pour le
groupe socialiste vous avez la parole
mon
cher monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les grandes
lois de décentralisation les années 1980
ont jeté les bases de notre démocratie
locale en conférant à la fois
l'autonomie et une dimension politique
et administrativ à nos collectivités
territoriales les deux textes dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui s'inscrivent dans
cette ligné des réformes qui innovent et
je m'attarderai particulièrement sur le
département car cette réforme le
modernisera
incontestablement le département et le
conseil général en sortiront dans une
configuration entièrement nouvelle en
opposition totale avec la loi de réforme
des collectivités territoriales du 16
décembre 2010 qui contribuait à
affaiblir les départements avec en
particulier la création du conseiller
territorial la proposition qui nous est
faite inscrit le département dans la
modernité en conférant en confortant
pardon sa dimension de collectivité de
proximité le département est par sa
nature et ses compétences l'échelon des
politiques de proximité
l'échelon des politiques de solidarité
sociale et de solidarité territoriale
cette dimension est réaffirmée par les
texte présenté par Monsieur le Ministre
de l'Intérieur qui supprime le
conseiller territorial et propose un
mode de scrutin novateur qui conjugue à
la fois la proximité du scrutin
majoritaire et la nécessaire
féminisation de cette assemblée le
scrutin majoritaire permet de répondre à
l'exigence de proximité des citoyens
avec leurs élus départementaux ce lien
fort élu territoire spécifique au
département nous devons le maintenir
mais cette exigence de proximité doit
respecter le principe de parité inscrit
dans la Constitution et ardemment
demandé par une immense majorité de nos
concitoyens cela a déjà été dit et
répété ici les assemblées
départementales sont constitués de 13 %
de femmes seulement sur 101 départements
seul 5 sont présidés par l'une d'entre
elles les progrès dans ce domaine sont
dérisoires d'une élection à l'autre
ainsi lors des dernières élection
cantonale de 2011 la proportion de
femmes élues a augmenté de 0,7 % par
rapport à 2008 alors que le nombre de
candidats était plus important qu'aux
élections cantonales précédentes lors du
débat sur l'égal accès des femmes et des
hommes mandats électoraux Jean-Pierre
chevennem alors ministre de l'Intérieur
déclara dans cette même assemblée il y a
13 ans de cela la sous-représentation
des femmes est un défi lancé à
l'universalisme républicain ce défi nous
tentons de le relever aujourd'hui pour
les élections départementales en
proposant ce mode de scrutin oui bien
sûr comme vous tous je souhaiterais que
les évolutions aillent d'elles-mêmees et
que les femmes soient représentées à
hauteur de leurs proportions dans le
corps électoral naturellement mais en
attendant ce rééquilibrage le recours à
la loi
me paraît nécessaire ce binô tant décrié
par l'opposition est une opportunité
pour développer de nouvelles formes de
coopération entre élus il n'est pas
interdit d'innover au contraire et puis
aujourd'hui les conseillers régionaux
défendent un même territoire et
travaillent très bien ensemble avec ce
nouveau système nous gagnerons en
efficacité et en audience auprès de nos
concitoyens mesure symbolique le
changement de dénomination permettra au
citoyens d'établir un lien direct entre
le conseiller départemental et les
politiques
départementales la suppression du
renouvellement trienal au profit d'un
renouvellement intégral participera
aussi de cette meilleure lisibilité et
permettra une plus grande efficacité des
politiques publiques le nouveau mode
d'élection nécessitera un redécoupage
des cantons nous sommes tous d'accord
pour constater que le mode actuel de
scrutin révèle d'énormes écarts de
population entre les cantons d'un même
département je prendrai l'exemple d'un
département que je connais bien le
lgaron l'écart est aujourd'hui de 1 à 10
entre le canton le plus peuplé et le
moins peuplé la carte
cantonale actuelle n'est pas
satisfaisante au regard du principe
constitutionnel d'égalité devant le
suffrage aujourd'hui il est temps de
mettre un terme à cette inégalité de
représentation liée à l'histoire
en divisant par deux le nombre de
cantons le gouvernement ne donne pas une
prime sans précédent à la représentation
des agglomération au détriment des
territoires ruraux comme l'affirme
l'opposition avec une mauvaise fois
ttiné d'amnésie ce qui se font
aujourd'hui les chentrres de la ruralité
ont accepté hier que les 6000
conseillers régionaux et généraux soi
remplacés par 3000 conseillers
territoriaux siégeant à la fois dans les
assemblées départementales et
régionales dans mon département le
nombre de cantons et d'élu donc auraiit
été réduit de 40 à 27 et la proximité
réduite d'autant la proximité nous
répétons tout c'est une exigence de nos
concitoyens ce texte réaffirme donc le
rôle de lien essentiel que joue le
conseiller départemental entre son
territoire et l'action publique menée à
l'échelle du département le
renouvellement de la présentation
politique est un autre de leur souhait
et je me félicite qu'ils puissent en
trouver un écho concret dans le projet
de loi qui nous est présenter
aujourd'hui mais surtout ce texte ouvre
la voie au renouveau territorial que les
élus locaux appellent de leur vœux un
renouveau territorial fondé sur la
confiance en l'intelligence de nos
territoires et qui devrait trouver une
traduction concrète dans l'acte 3 de la
décentralisation merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à Madame Catherine
trendely pour le groupe
UMP monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le ministre ce texte
mon éminent collègue jean-jacquesest l'a
exprimé hier soir est une remise en
cause profonde de la réformme que notre
majorité a défendu il y a 2 ans elle
prévoyait de favoriser
l'intercommunalité de départementaliser
la vie politique et de régionaliser les
politiques
publiques vous avez certes gardé la
première idée et nous en avons déjà
discuté dans différents textes depuis et
vous avez choisi d'abandonner tout
simplement les deux autres c'est votre
choix et nous ne pouvons pas le
partager vous reprenez aujourd'hui à
votre compte un point ant de ce texte
issu des travaux de notre majorité
l'élection des délégués communautaires
au suffrage universel direct qui
constitue pour nous un point central de
la réforme territoriale de 2010 et qui
permettra de renforcer la légitimité des
intercommunalités aux yeux de nos
concitoyens en effet ces derniers
participeront ainsi directement à la
désignation de ceux des conseillers
municipaux qui seront délégués
communautaires et nous ne pouvons que
nous en réjouir
il s'agit là d'un progrès considérable
auquel nous tenons car il garantit la
légitimité des conseils municipaux des
maires et donc des communes tout en
renforçant le caractère démocratique du
fonctionnement des EPCI qui lève l'impôt
mais paradoxalement ne sont pas pour
l'heure concerné par le suffrage
universel le système du fléchage permet
de répondre à cette
exigence nous avions fait ce choix il y
a 2 ans au côté du gouvernement alors
qu'il y avait aussi d'autres
possibilités envisageables mais nous ne
souhaitions pas porter atteinte à la
légitimité du maire laquelle aurait été
concurrencé si on l'avait retenu la
désignation des conseillers
communautaires par un scrutin
autonome avec cette élection les
citoyens vont s'approprier les débats
communautaires l'intercommunalité ne
sera plus une structure éloignée presque
désincarnée pour lesé
lecteur ce sujet vous l'avez compris est
fondamental au 1er janvier 2012 pour
mémoire on dénombit 2581
EPCI qui rassemblent 59,3 millions
d'habitants et couvre
35303 communes un deuxème sujet tout
aussi important est celui des petites
commune je veux parler de la question du
nombre d'habitants déterminant
l'obligation de présenter une liste en
effet cette question nous le savons
divise les maires de France certains
pensent que cette obligation doit
concerner toutes les communes d'autres
qu'il ne faut pas changer le système
actuel le scrutin de liste qui
s'applique actuellement au commune de
plus de 3500 habitants a des avantages
il permet d'avoir une majorité cohérente
et d'assurer la parité un élément
toutefois doit être pris en
considération plus on abaisse le seuil
plus on aura de difficultés à présenter
au moins deux listes voire même à en
constituer une seule car la constitution
d'une liste complète et paritaire est
complexe dans les petites communes le
risque de faire perdre à nos concitoyens
leur intérêt pour le scrutin municipal
qui est aujourd'hui le scrutin préféré
des Français néanmoins j'en conviens un
seuil à baissé permet de diversifier la
composition des conseils municipaux nous
proposons donc de fixer ce seuil à 2000
habitants seuil certes non juridique
mais lisible pour nos collègues maires
des petites communes puisqu'il s'agit du
seuil Inc pour définir une commune
rurale la question de légal accès des
hommes et des femmes aux fonctions
électives est un objectif partagé par
l'ensemble des partis politiques notre
retard reste considérable par rapport à
de nombreuses démocraties malgré
l'inscription dans la Constitution du
principe de l'égal accès des hommes et
des femmes au mandat électoraux au
fonctions
électives le juge constitutionnel a
cependant
rappelé le que le principe n'avait pas
pour objet et ne saurait avoir pour
effet de priver le législateur de la
faculté qu' il tient de l'article 34 de
la Constitution de fixer le régime
électoral des assemblées aussi il
considère que le législateur doit
conserver toute l'attitude dans le choix
des modes de scrutin mais mes chers
collègues nous étions bien loin
d'imaginer que l'actuelle majorité
allait nous proposer une un mode de
scrutin on ne peut plus baroque inéit en
droit français il n'existe nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde
un mode de
scrutin qui rend les deux élus le binô
des conseillers départementaux solidaire
devant le scrutin avec toutes les
conséquences associées à cette
solidarité et une fois élu les deux
conseillers deviendront indépendant l'un
de l'autre que de questionnement que
d'incertitude quel sera leur mode de
fonctionnement sur le terrain ils seront
forcément en
concurrence ils seront en concurrence
sur un même territoire
ce territoire parlons-en qui sera un qu
ce ce ce territoire qui sera un canton
surdimensionné qui conduira couper le
lien de proximité entre l'élu et ses
électeurs et tout particulièrement dans
les
zones particulièrement faiblement peuplé
ce redécoupage basé sur une logique
purement démographique conduira
inéluctablement à porter un coup dur à
la cohérence territoriale et à sacrifier
la ruralité et cela tout simplement est
inacceptable aussi compte tenu de
l'ensemble de ces enjeux nous serons
extrêmement déterminés et combatifs tout
au long de ces débats je vous
remercie merci ma cherre collègue
monsieur le ministre pour répondre aux
orateurs je vous en
prie
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je souhaite
évidemment vous répondre pour permettre
au débat d'avancer même si travers les
motions de procédure et puis l'ÉE des
articles des amendements je ne doute pas
que notre débat va
s'enrichir je souhaite remercier à
nouveau le rapporteur le sénateur Michel
delb pour la qualité du travail qu'il a
effectué
en lien avec le président de votre
commission des Lois Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Sueur et je ne doute pas monsieur le
ministre que vous allez tout faire pour
permettre de convaincre le maximum de
sénateurs autour de ce projet je vais
répondre aux différents éléments évoqués
lors de cette discussion générale en
soulignant là aussi la qualité des
propos tenus par des hommes et des
femmes d'expérience qui représentent nos
territoire même quand il n'allait pas
dans le sens du projet que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présenter au nom du
gouvernement je veux remercier tout
particulièrement parmi d'autres bien sûr
le sénateur Kaltenbach pour
l'appréciation positive portée au nom du
groupe socialiste sur le texte qui vous
est soumis je voudrais au
préalable revenir sur la préparation de
ce texte important pour nos institutions
comme l'ont rappelé nombre d'orateurs
comme j'avais eu l'occasion de le
souligner hier jamais ce projet de loi
n'aurait pu voir le jour sans un
dialogue approfondi avec les
représentants des collectivités
territoriales et des formations
politiques et il m'a paraît important de
souligner qu'elle qu'elle a été la place
de la concertation dans sa préparation
du dialogue et je refute très nettement
toute accusation de précipitation et je
tiens à vous à cet égard que j'ai
rencontré dans ce cadre les dirigeants
des
formations politique représenté par un
groupe parlementaire et plusieurs
d'entre vous participaient à ces
rencontres place bovau je reconnais mais
nous en étions expliqués avec le
président Godin et avec Jean-François
Copé que à ce moment-là le dialogue
était plus difficile avec l'UMP pour des
raisons internes à cette formation mais
nous avions
nous avions nous avions
convenu je
vous je ne vous donne aucune leçon nous
avions convenu nous avions convenu je
vous donne cette information puisque
l'un d'entre vous me disait qu'il n'y
avait pas eu de rencontre hier je vous
donne cette information et
avant que vous criez laissez-moi aller
jusqu'au bout pour vous dire au
contraire qu'avec le président Godin et
avec Jean-François Copé nous avions
échanger rapidement pour marquer sans
doute des désaccords eux-mêmes on
avaient parlé avec le président de la
République et je veux uniquement donner
la raison et non pas marquer un fait de
la vie politique qui touche l'ensemble
des formations politiques donc
laissez-moi aller jusqu'au bout et j'ai
un souvenir précis de ce qui a été dit
alors à l'occasion de ces dialogues j'ai
également rencontrer plusieurs
associations d'élus la MF laadf et la
DCF et au cours de ces entretiens j'ai
constaté un réel soutien pour les
principales dispositions que contient ce
texte Président mzard vous avez évoqué
un silence assourdissant de l'ADF et je
me permets de vous renvoyer au texte
qu'elle a adopté le 9 janvier 2013 et
qu'elle a publié texte dans lequel le
bureau de l'ADF reconnaît au mode de
scrutin binominal à deux tours je cite
une totale efficacité concernant
l'égalité des femmes et des hommes
sans pour autant rompre le lien
indispensable entre les élus et leur
territoire je rappelle également les
déclaration du président de l'Assemblée
des communautés de France qui s'est
félicité de la confirmation du principe
de l'élection directe des conseillers
intercommunaux dans le cadre du scrutin
municipal le présent projet de loi a été
rédigé aussi donc à la lumière de ces
échanges là aussi souvent très riches je
souhaiterais pouvoir revenir sur les
principaux points de la réforme qui ont
été évoqués je souhaite d'abord évoquer
le scrutin binominal majoritaire que
propose aujourd'hui le gouvernement
plusieurs d'entre vous j'y reviendrai se
sont exprimés messieur yest mesar ou ce
mode de scrutin novateur il est oui
incontestablement a été proposé par
Michel André alors présidente de la
délégation au droits des femmes de votre
assemblée dès 2010 Madame Bernadette
Bour le rappeler dans son rapport au
titre si éloquent il faut sauver la
parité il répond très clairement à deux
enjeux majeurs la nécessité de renforcer
la parité et l'exigence de proximité à
laquelle le gouvernement est également
attaché c'est la
condition d'un renforcement de la
légitimité des conseillers
départementaux rétabli par ce
gouvernement après la suppression des
conseillers territoriaux ce seront
toujours des élus de terrain apprécier
les électeurs et suffisamment
représentatifs pour être en prise avec
les enjeux contemporains je
récapitule le conseiller territorial
mettait à la fois en difficulté la
région et le département et ce fait
était reconnu aussi bien par des élus de
la droite que de la
gauche le conseiller territorial ne
permettez pas un lien
direct vu la complexité de ce conseiller
avec les électeurs et enfin le
conseiller territorial et ça vous avait
été reproché ne permettez pas la parité
alors quand on est pour la parité quand
on est pour le département et quand on
est pour la proximité on doit se
féliciter de la capacité d'invention à
la fois du Sénat et du Gouvernement sur
ce
sujetl certains d'entre vous soutiennent
le scrutin majoritaire unom chè madame
certains d'entre vous soutiennent le
scrutin majoritaire une nominal le
gouvernement ne peut se satisfaire de ce
statut quo trop défavorable à la parité
comme l'a souligné madame Gontier main
dans son rapport je comprends bien
l'analyse qui était faite par vous
encore madame la sénatrice Duin il y a
un instant sur oui ça n'est pas possible
13,5 % de femmes représentées dans les
départements ça n'est pas normal c'est
même scandaleux donc il faut aller plus
loin or nous
constatons que quand il y a le scrutin
majoritaire et quand il n'y a pas des
règles précises comme c'est le cas sur
des scrutins de liste ou comme nous vous
le proposons et bien la cause des femmes
n'avance pas et dans la réalité sur un
tout autre scrutin quand on regarde
celui des élections législatives où il y
a pourtant des pénalités financière très
importante quand on regarde de près les
choses je dois constater que la parité
avance d'un côté et qu'elle n'avance pas
de l'autre alors pour faire avancer la
parité et oui le scrutin binominal il
permet d'être plus efficace la dimension
binominale du scrutin proposé par le
gouvernement va permettre d'atteindre
dès 2015 la parité dans les conseils
départementaux et quel chemin parcouru
depuis la loi de du 6 juin 2000 tendante
à favoriser l'égal accès des femmes et
des hommes aux mandats électoraux et
fonctions électives avec le présent
projet de loi c'est la parité objectif à
valeur constitutionnelle dans la quasi
totalité des assemblées locales qui
pourra être atteinte notre pays est
ainsi fait et vous le souhaitez dans
bien des aspects de la société que nous
avons besoin souvent pour faire avancer
un certain nombre de causes nous avons
besoin de la loi et de la règle et ainsi
la parité pourra s'imposer partout vous
avez été nombreux à souligner
la nécessaire proximité entre les élus
départementaux et les électeurs et c'est
pour cette raison que le gouvernement a
proposé un mode de scrutin qui préserve
un lien fort entre les électeurs et
leurs élus avec un scrutin majoritaire
par canton dont le nombre dont le nombre
restera légèrement supérieur à la moitié
du nombre actuel de canton Président
mzard vous me posez la question vous
avez posé la question de la
constitutionnalité du scrittin binominal
majoritaire sur deux points c'était une
question je souhaite vous donner
quelques éléments de réflexion d'abord
et bien entendu la notion de
représentativité peut-être partagé de
manière binominale au titre de la
représentation d'un même territoire dans
le cas contraire les listes prévu dans
le cadre de l'élection des conseils
régionaux ne serait pas constitutionnel
quant au principe de l'individ
l'égalité de représentation que vous
évoquez ne na pas été fait référence au
Conseil d'État où le rapporteur s'est
penché de manière exhaustive sur les
principes constitutionnels auquel
devrait veiller le gouvernement dans la
rédaction de son projet de loi j'entends
bien également vos
inquiétudes de la part de plusieurs
orateurs sur le redécoupage cantonal et
votre souhait qu'il soit réalisé par la
voie législative mais l'article 34 de la
Constitution cité à plusieurs reprises
prévoit que la loi fixe les règles
concernant le régime électoral des
assemblées locales et c'est bien le sens
du présent projet de loi à son article
23 que de fixer les règles c'est-à-dire
les dispositions de portée générale
concernant le redécoupage cantonal sur
la base de ces règles l'article L 31132
du code génér des collectivités
territoriales prévoit dans sa version
actuellement en vigueur que les
modifications des limites territorial
des cantons les créations et
suppressions de Canton et le transfert
du siège de leur cheflieu sont décidés
par décret en Conseil d'État après
consultation du conseil général ces
dispositions sont en conformité avec la
volonté du pouvoir constituant qui ne
prévoit pas que les limites des cantons
soi définies par la loi
toujours dans un souci de dialogue je
souhaiterais évoquer avec vous notre
volonté commune à la suite de ce que je
viens de dire que le redécoupage des
cantons soit fait de façon
équilibrée c'est un vrai débat qui n'est
pas facile aborder en tenant compte de
la démographie mais aussi des
territoires cette prise en compte de la
démographie elle est
indispensable parce que c'est la règle
qui découle de la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnelle dans sa
décision du 8 janvier 2009 il a validé
la conformité à la Constitution de la
règle de l'écart de plus ou moins 20 %
qu'avait prévu le législateur pour le
redécoupage des circonscriptions
législative dans l'avis spécialement
demandé par le gouvernement au Conseil
d'État parce que évidemment au vu de la
réalité des départements et des cantons
nous avions besoin de cet avis la haute
juridiction administrative
a confirmé la prise en compte de cette
règle de l'écart de plus moins 20 % par
rapport à la moyenne des cantons dans un
département dans la mesure où le Conseil
constitutionnel et le Conseil d'État
apprécieront les critères du redécoupage
puis leur mise en œuvre par le
gouvernement il n'est pas possible pour
le ministre que je suis pour le
gouvernement de ne pas se conformer à
ces exigences dans le présent projet de
loi des exceptions selon des critères
géographiques ou pour des motifs
d'intérêt général pourront cependant
être prévu au cas par cas j'ai entendu
des
intervention très pertinent par exemple
sur les cantons en montagne en zonees
rural et je sais que le rapporteur est
particulièrement sensible à ce sujet
nous avons tenu à le faire
figurer à l'article 23 du projet de loi
et ce sera bien l'approche retenue dans
le cas du redécoupage cantonal pour
tenir compte des territoires et de leur
spécificité lorsque cela sera pertinent
vous l'avez indiqué Monsieur an le
redécoupage cantonal est nécessaire et
nous devons le réaliser avec les
critères les plus clairs si nous avions
gardé le même mode de scrutin qui ne
permet pas la parité et qui date depuis
longtemps le même redécoupage il aurait
fallu redécouper exactement sur les
mêmes
et les problèmes que nous avons à
traiter vous les auriez trouvés ceux qui
critiquent ce système ne propose pas au
fond une alternative ne propose pas un
autre dispositif sinon de ne pas
respecter les règles démographiques et
surtout de ne pas respecter la parité je
ne vois pas aujourd'hui dans notre débat
l'alternative l'autre proposition qui
permet de garder à la fois la force du
département la parité et la proximité
dont chacun d'entre vous dont chacun
d'entre vous aujourd'hui se réclame
madame Delphine bataille vous avez
évoqué ces questions et vous avez
souhaité que le gouvernement avance dans
la voie des exceptions démographiques et
les exceptions géographiques et je
voudrais vous dire comment nous pouvons
essayer d'y répondre et je rappelais la
règle du 20 % mais nous devons
travailler donc sur ces exceptions si
elles sont objectivement établies par la
géographie les
représentants des citooyens à n'importe
quel échelon représente d'abord
évidemment des électeurs avant de
représenter des hectares mais en même
temps il faut être conscient et vous
l'avez dit de l'étendue des cantons du
nombre de communes de la typographie de
ces territoire et bien ces éléments il
va falloir les intégrer les enrichir
dans la loi pour permettre précisément
au moment du redécoupage avec l'avis des
conseils généraux pour que le Conseil
d'État puisqu'il sera saisi département
par département pour pouvoir prendre sa
décision ensuite puisse intégrer à la
fois la règle du 20 % mais également les
critères que vous avez évoqué et le
gouvernement est particulièrement
sensible et ouvert à ces élémentsl ceux
qui sont favorables évidemment à ce
système à ce dispositif du binôme
doivent savoir que nous allons intégrer
ces critères et donc il va falloir pour
les montagnes pour les îles pour les
vallées ou d'autres territoires intégrer
ces éléments j'ai d'ailleurs de ce point
de vue là et je le dis dans ce débat sur
la typographie le nombre
d'habitants
les inégalités qui existent dans les
partartement j'ai particulièrement
apprécié le talent de Monsieur Louis
ngre en particulier dans sa tentative de
montrer
de démonstration des véléités ruralcid
du gouvernement et je demande d'ailleurs
au maire de Cagne surmer de transmettre
notre amical salut à Eric soioti élu du
canton de Saint-Martin vezubi qui comme
chacun le sait comprend
1473 habitants alors qu'il y a des
cantons dans les alpes maritimes qui
dépassent les 40000 habitants et qui
grâce à cette compétence exceptionnelle
lui assure aussi une maîtrise
particulièrement pointue du
développement d'un département de plus
d'un million d'habitants quand on
regarde ces chiffres dans le département
des Alpes Maritimes nous pouvons nous
mettre très vite d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut de ce point de vue-là un
changement rapide pour que la légitimité
de tous les élus ne soit pas en
discussion ce devoir d'objectivité
suppose un véritable dialogue préalable
vous avez raison il ne peut pas nous
répondre c'est le sens de la discussion
qui se tient ici et à cet égard je tiens
à préciser à mon ami le sénateur mard de
nouveau que ce n'est pas le gouvernement
mais il le sait mais il le sait qui a
soulevé l'irvabilité de certains
amendements ayant trait aux effectifs
des conseils départementaux au titre de
l'article 40 de la Constitution le
Gouvernement est à l'écoute des
propositions formulées au sein du Sénat
quant à la définition du seuil à partir
dequel le scrutin de liste doit
s'appliquer dans les communes dans le
projet loi du gouvernement je m'en suis
expliqué hier c'est un seuil de 1000
habitants point d'ancrage entre les
différentes propositions les différents
projets évoqués qui vous a proposés
monsieur hanom monsieur zoketo ont
évoqué la nécessité d'augmenter quelque
peu ce seuil par rapport au projet du
gouvernement pour le porter à 1500
habitants madame assassie a au contraire
évoquer un seuil à 500 habitants et
c'est aussi le souhait de Monsieur ass
qui nous manque ce soir ce sont deux
options possibles cruellement
cruellement je le partage je partage cet
avis avec vous en revanche le
gouvernement ne sera pas favorable à un
seuil trop élevé qui ne permettrait pas
d'atteindre l'un des objectifs de la
réforme à savoir l'amélioration de la
parité au sein des conseils municipaux
je note à cet égard que Monsieur yest
oui la parité est une obsession madame
oui vous avez raison la parité est une
obsession oui
ouais c'est parce que j'avais envie que
vous je souhaitais que vous fassiez
cette remarque que je vous interpellis
de nouveau alors oui la parité est une
obsession et je note à cet
égard que Monsieur yest qui a soutenu la
proposition du gouvernement précédent
cette proposition prévoyait également un
seuil à 500 habitants et aujourd'hui
vous estimez je vous cite qu'un seuil de
habitants et pertinent alors je connais
l'indépendance de Monsieur yest et de
bien d'autres sénateurs mais je relève
quand même un certain nombre de
contradiction entre pour certains
d'entre vous le soutien un projet de loi
et aujourd'hui la proposition qui vous
est faite mais je vous ai dit hier je
vous ai dit hier que le gouvernement
était ouvert sur cette question là et
que il fallait dans les proposition
au-delà du principe que je viens
d'évoquer regardez quel était le seuil
aujourd'hui sans doute le plus pertinent
ce projet de loi marque également une
étape de démocratisation de
l'intercommunalité et le Gouvernement
est favorable à permettre cette étape
nouvelle dans l'approfondissement de la
démocratie pour les intercommunalités
peut-être plus tard d'ailleurs celle-ci
va-t-elle évoluer davantage bien
évidemment et que pour beaucoup
considérant l'évolution de
l'intercommunalité son murissement
l'achèvement de la carte intercommunale
la pratique en faisant à chaque fois
attention à la la commune qui reste
cette ce lieu unique cette relation
particulière qui existe dans notre pays
il faut évidemment la préserver je
voudrais rassurer madame Assassi sur ses
craintes ce n'est pas une étape vers la
disparition des communes mais il n nulle
question de remettre en cause l'chelon
communal qui reste essentiel dans
l'organisation territoriale mais là
aussi à permettre une plus grande
lisibilité pour nos au citoyens par
rapport à l'intercommunalité vu les
compétences aujourd'hui qu'elle gère
qu'elle assume et vu les budget
particulièrement important qu'elle gère
ces réformes rendront nécessaires des
adaptations dont votre commission des
Lois a déjà eu l'occasion de débattre
dans les communes au sein desquelles
s'appliquera le scrutin de liste
l'obligation de déposer monsieur le
rapporteur vous l'avez dit de déposer
des listes complètes devra être
obligatoire et à la lumière de ces
enjeux votre assemblée sera définir le
meilleur seuil pour répondre au défis de
la parité tout en garantissant le
meilleur exercice de la démocratie au
sein de nos 36000 communes je voudrais
enfin revenir sur les modifications
proposées du calendrier électoral je
rappelle que la précédente majorité
avait modifié le calendrier pour mettre
en place le conseiller territorial c'est
dans la logique du texte il est dès lors
naturel dès l'instant où l'on abroche
les dispositions relatives au conseiller
territorial de revenir sur le calendrier
électoral qui avait été prévu
spécifiquement pour ce dispositif je
soulligne que c'est la précédente
majorité qui a raccourci le mandat des
conseillers régionaux et celui des
conseillers généraux par la loi du 16
février 2010 de 2 ans pour les élus
régionaux et de 3 ans pour les
conseillers généraux les dates normales
était 2016 pour les élections régionales
et 2017 pour la série cantonale en
l'augmentant d'un an nous vous proposons
ainsi de rapprocher la durée des mandats
des conseillers régionaux et généraux
élus en 2010 et en 2011 de la durée
classique de ces mandats reporter les
élections cantonales et régionales
plutôt que les élections municipales
permet aussi de conserver la durée
normale du mandat des conseillers
municipaux élus en 2008
à l'occasion d'un changement qui avait
déjà eu lieu parce qu'il y avait une
élection présidentielle en 2007 cette
année pour les conseillers municipaux
élus en 2001 nous savons pour ceux qui
sommes des élus de ces commune que c'est
particulièrement long et donc nous
n'avons pas souhaité modifier l'ordre
des élections locales d'ici le prochain
renouvellement de votre assemblée parce
qu'elle réduit la fréquence à laquelle
nos concitoyens sont appelés à se
prononcer la concomitance des élections
locales stimule je crois la
participation électorale les faits ont
démontré que le couple élection
régionale et élection cantonale
permettent en tout cas il faut l'espérer
une plus forte mobilisation du corps
électoral monsieur yest vous nous
suggérez une autre forme de concomitance
en proposant d'organiser simultanément
les élections régionales et les
élections européennes pourquoi pas je
veux uniquement
m'interroger sur la cohérence d'un tel
choix quel lien peut-on établir entre
les deux scrutins par ailleurs les
élections européennes c'est une élection
un seul tour municipal c'est à deux
tours c'est quand même éloigné comme
type de scrutin scrutin essentiellement
local avec un scrutin qui est très
politisé nous le savons l'intérêt des
électeurs pour les scrutins régionaux et
départementaux lorsqu'ils sont organisé
simultanément n'est pas un hasard
est marques de leur intérêt je l'espère
là aussi pour l'action de ces deux
échelons locaux et pour leur
articulation dans les meilleures
conditions vous avez président yest
formulé d'autres propositions sur
lesquelles je n'en doute pas nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir au cours du débat
et que le gouvernement observera avec
beaucoup d'intérêt monsieur al Richard
nous a une nouvelle fois montré son
exceptionnelle connaissance des
collectivités
locales comme bien d'autres en théorie
comme en pratique et je rappelle à ceux
qui l'ignoreraient que vous avez été le
rapporteur de la loi historique du 2
mars 1982 et votre créativité juridique
a été encore fort utile à ces travaux et
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir dans
la discussion des amendements je
remercie beaucoup d'ailleurs Monsieur
Jean Boyet des mots particulièrement
républicains qu'il a eu à mon égard et
je veux lui dire très sincèrement
combien le gouvernement entend préserver
un équilibre entre l' démocratique et la
préservation des territoires ruraux
monsieur Colomba on se connaî depuis
bien longtemps mais j'ai quand même cru
déceler quelques contradiction dans vos
propos je vous ai connu comme un très
grand réformateur mais vous n'êtes ni
pour la
proportionnelle ni pour le binominal et
je n'imagine pas que vous soyez vous un
partisan vous du statut que vous ne
vouliez pas vous prendre en compte la
parité et l'équilibre des territoires si
on ne veut pas de la proportionnelle et
nous l'avons pas voulu pour ce scrutin
et si on ne veut pas du statu quo et si
on veut la parité il faut avancer et il
faut donc oui une proposition qui est
innovante et nouvelle et je le répète
encore une nouvelle fois qui vient
d'abord de votre assemblée je remercie
ronand Dantec de son soutien et du S et
du soutien de son groupe au projet de
loi je crois que y ded a pertinemment et
précisément démontré comment le binôme
peut fonctionner sans
difficulté comment ces deux élus peuvent
faire bloc pour défendre leur canton et
également se répartir les
responsabilités et je note à cet égard
et je le rappellerai que dans toutes les
régions de
France les conseillers régionaux
prouvent qu'il soit de la majorité ou
qu'il soit de l'opposition combien il
savent facilement se répartir les
responsabilités dans les conseils
d'administration des lycées des
établissements publics alors qu'ils sont
eux aussi collectivement élus d'un
territoire je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que dans le conseiller territorial vous
aviez même imaginer que le suppléent
puisse assumer un certain nombre de
responsabilités mais enfin soyons
sérieux un instant sur un territoire
deux candidats qui forment un binôme du
même camp politique qui représente un
territoire du même camp politique mais
vous le savez bien enfin j'attends de
voir une candidature commune umpps mais
tout est possible qui font partie qui
s'entendent qui travaillent ensemble qui
se répartissent le territoire l'un maire
d'un du sud de territoire l'autre
premier adjoint de l'autre territoire
ils travailleront ensemble pendant la
campagne et il travaillont ensemble
après leur élection ce binôme il
mais madame vous parlez beaucoup de
mariage vous parlez beaucoup de Pax je
vous invite à sortir de ce débat et à
revenir au débat sur les cantonnales le
binô et ceux qui seront élus
travailleront ensemble parce que
ensemble ils auront battu une
candidature un projet et qu'ils auront
en plus reçu le mandat des électeurs
pour le mettre en
œuvre j'ai failli m'étonner j'ai failli
m'étonner que Monsieur j'ai failli
m'étonner Monsieur Philippe Bas
manifeste une extrême exigence sur les
futures règles du découpage cantonal
alors qu'elles sont exactement les mêmes
que celles que le gouvernement précédent
avait prévu d'utiliser pour le découpage
des cantons d'élection des conseillers
territoriaux et j'ai vraiment trouvé
étonnante la suspission de Monsieur bas
à l'égard du Conseil d'État qui
ressortait de ses propos alors qu'il
connaît pourtant bien et ce que le
gouvernement précédent a fait et ce que
le Conseil d'État fait en général sur ce
sujet-l et à cet égard comment Monsieur
po pouvez-vous parler de
tripatouillage alors que le gouvernement
a demandé un avis au Conseil d'État sur
les règles du
redécoupage intégrer ses propositions
dans le projet de loi et soumettra à
cette autorité a autant de décret qu'il
y a de département concernés et je le
dis très sereinement au sénateurs de
l'UM M P au vu le travail de la
commission présidée par Monsieur Guenard
sur le découpage législatif je leur
suggère de réviser leur argumentaire
concernant le
tripatouillage mesdames et messieurs
au-delà de ces pic des uns et des autres
je veux vous dire encore une fois que le
gouvernement est à l'écoute du Sénat et
que si nous avons présenté ce texte qui
concerne l'avenir des territoires
d'abord de votre assemblée c'est par
respect à l'égard du Sénat c'est parce
que nous partageons je crois la même
volonté celle de préserver le
département qui est au cœur de la
République celle de préserver cette
proximité que vous avez tous évoqué et
en même temps de moderniser le canton à
travers la parité et dans le respect
aussi des évolutions démographiques
c'est fort de ces convictions et des
propositions que je vous ai faites que
le gouvernement sera à votre écoute tout
au long de ce débat est dans la bonne
humeur
merci merci Monsieur le le ministre la
discussion générale est donc close et
nous allons donc examiner successivement
les deux motions portant sur le projet
de loi puis la motion portant sur le
projet de loi organique nous aborderons
ensuite l'examen des articles du projet
puis ceux du projet de loi organique
nous en arrivons donc à la motion
tendante à poser à opposer l'exception
d'irrecevabilité et la parole est à
monsieur Jean-Jacques y non monsieur
Portell ah Monsieur Portelli pardon pour
a
ça monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai donc l'honneur de
d'opposer au au nom du groupe P
l'exception d'irrecevabilité au projet
de loi relatif à l'élection des
conseillers départementaux des
conseillers municipaux des délégués
communautaires et modifiant le
calendrier électoral cette
irrecevabilité constitutionnelle
concerne trois dispositions essentielles
du projet de loi qui est soumis à notre
examen la première concerne le nouveau
mode d'élection des conseillers
départementaux celui-ci on l'a rappelé
plusieurs fois aujourd'hui est
caractérisé bien évidemment par
l'invention du binôme des candidats
justifiés par la volonté d'imposer la
parité cette invention ne correspond à
aucun des deux types de scrutin existant
en France et dans les grands États
démocratiques à savoir le scrutin
uninominal ou le scrutin de liste
elle aura pour conséquence de créer un
mode de représentation relativement
baroque le couple de candidat sera
paritaire jusque dans ses
suppléentss pourtant en cas de mission
du suppléant si il devient titulaire le
siège devra rester vacant jusqu'à la fin
du mandat qui dure je vous le rappelle 6
ans les deux élus seront solidaires y
compris financièrement durant la
campagne mais indépendant après ils
pourront même faire des choix politiques
divergents le candidat à de têtes
devenant schizophrène ce qui pose la
question de la sincérité d'un tel
scrutin et donc de sa
constitutionnalité rien nempêch le
gouvernement s'il tenait à la parité
donc je vous rappelle que dans la
Constitution elle est un objectif et non
une obligation de résultat rien ne
l'empêcher de proposer le seul système
qui permette de garantir la parité à
savoir un scrutin de liste ce scrutin de
liste pouvait être proportionnel mais il
pouvait être aussi majoritaire si on
avait établi une liste paritaire dont
chacun des membres était fléché sur un
canton différent qui aurait été élu au
scrutin uninominal
mais bon vous avez préféré inventer un
système dont je connais qu'une seule
application c'est au Chili pour les
élections législatives mais je vous
rappelle qu'au chilé il est inventé pour
permettre à l'électeur de choisir en
dehors de toute règle de parité
d'ailleurs l'un des deux candidats
proposés par une coalition de partis
cétait au lendemain de la chite du Gén
du dictateur pinoché quand les
socialistes ont fait alliance avec les
démocrates chrétiens ils ont présenter
des listes à deux dans chaque
circonscription et on choisissait un un
candidat mais non pas deux on n lisait
pas deux mais un donc voilà première
euh anomalie 2è conséquence de de
l'instauration de la règle du binôme le
projet de loi réduit évidemment le
nombre de cantons par département en le
divisant par 2 ce que dit l'article 3
cette réduction du nombre de cantons va
se faire automatiquement au détriment
des territoires ruraux dont les cantons
couvriront une superficie démesurée et
un nombre élevé de communes
pourra d'après les calculs qui ont été
faits aller jusqu'à créer des cantons de
habitants et donc cela veut dire qu'on
urbanisera définitivement la
représentation
départementale alors n'oublions pas que
le canton c'est une circonscription
électorale c'est aussi une
circonscription administrative de
proximité et dans ces conditions le
canton n'existera plus et quelle sera
d'ailleurs la différence qu'il y aura
entre un canton ma en maxi canton
c'était déjà le problème d'ailleurs des
conseillers territoriaux et les grands
intercommunalités qui ont été créé du
fait de la loi sur la réforme
territoriale où verra-t-on la différence
sinon dans leur mode de représentation
alors je rappelle en passant vous le
savez mieux que moi que le Sénat assure
la représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la République c'est
l'article 24 de la Constitution qu' est
l'émanation des collectivités par le
vote des représentants de celle-ci or en
affaiblissant la représentation des
territoires ruraux au sein du conseil
départemental le projet de loi affecte
également paricocher le représentation
au sein du Sénat et donc porte atteinte
à l'article 24 de la Constitution donc
sur ce premier point le projet de loi
nous paraît contraire à plusieurs
impératifs d'intérêt général tels qu'ils
sont reconnus par la jurisprudence du
Conseil
constitutionnel la seconde disposition
qui nous dérange c'est celle qui
concerne le report des élections
cantonales et
régionales la durée du mandat des
conseillers généraux puisqu'il s'appelle
toujours généraux et régionaux avaient
été fixés avant la loi sur les conseill
et territoriaux et donc la date des
nouvelles élections si le choix des
candidats et le vote des électeurs ont
été conditionné par cette particularité
d'un mandat court pour un corps d'élu en
voie d'extinction et d'ailleurs
l'argument est rappelé dans les Cahiers
du Conseil constitutionnel qui commente
la décision du 17 février 2010 rendue
par le conseil et de ce fait ces
conseillers généraux et régionaux vont
voir la durée de leur mandat prolongé de
25 à 33 % ce qui n'a jamais été accepté
par le Conseil constitutionnel dans sa
jurisprudence par ailleurs en repoussant
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux à
2015 le projet de loi entraîne la
désignation d'une partie des sénateurs
par un collège électoral composé en
partie de conseillers généraux en fin de
mandat or toujours dans les commentaires
que le Conseil fait de ces décisions à
propos de la décision du 15 décembre
2005 qui portait justement sur les dates
de renouvellement du Sénat
il est précisé que la dite loi j'ouvre
les guillemets assure durablement que
les sénateurs ne seront pas élus par des
grands électeurs en fin de mandat ils le
seront soit par des élus locaux en début
de mandat soit par des élus locaux à
mi-mandat je continue ma citation au
regard du principe constitutionnel selon
lequel le Sénat représente les
collectivités territoriales il est
préférable de rapprocher à l'avenir
l'élection des sénateurs de la
désignation par les citoyens de la
majeure partie du collège électoral
sénatorial
jusqu'à présent le renouvellement du
Sénat a toujours fait suite au
renouvellement des conseillers généraux
1998 2001 2004 2008 2011 l'élection de
ces nouveaux conseillers départementaux
en 2015 est susceptible donc d'entraîner
une rupture avec la concordance des
dates évoquées et une mauvaise
représentation au regard de ce critère
d'une partie des territoires et cela est
d'autant plus grave lorsque l'on sait
que le gouvernement a l'intention
matérialiser déjà dans un avant projet
de loi de d'accorder aux conseillers
généraux et régionaux un droit de vote
multiple un droit de vote multiple avec
une élection reportée et bien ça aboutit
à fausser tout simplement le scrutin
enfin je vous rappelle que le rapport le
report des élections locales doit être
motivé par un impératif d'intérêt
général or la date retenu jusqu'alors
avait été validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 17
février 2010 lorsque celui-ci a validé
la durée des mandats tout comme il avait
validé la tenue concomitante de ces deux
élections avec le motif d'intérêt
général qui avait été souligné à
l'époque à savoir permettre de limiter
l'abstention en regroupant les élections
locales l'étalement proposé aujourd'hui
n'est justifié par aucun argument
sérieux
sinon le trop grand nombre d'élections
alors que justement leur regroupement
permettrait de combattre l'abstention
donc de ce second point de vue le report
des élections départementales et
régionales nous semble contraire à la
Constitution le 3è la 3è disposition
concerne les élections municipales à
Paris depuis la loi du 31 décembre 1982
les communes de Paris Lyon et Marseille
sont régies par des dispositions qui
sont adoptées par parallèlement en ce
qui concerne les élections municipales
puisque ces trois grandes communes sont
les seules à être divisé en
arrondissement cette spécificité avait
d'ailleurs été consacré par le Conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 28
décembre
1982 bizarrement le projet de loi qui
nous est proposé ne concerne que Paris
pour modifier le nombre des conseillers
élus par arrondissement bien entendu ce
cette modification concerne les trois
arrondissements de droite qui voi le
représent amoindri au profit de trois
arrondissements de gauche mais qu'en
est-il de Lyon et de
Marseille rien il s'agit donc là d'une
atteinte caractérisée au principe de
l'égalité devant la loi et donc d'une
atteinte à un principe constitutionnel
constamment affirmé par le Conseil
constitutionnel mes chers collègues pour
ces trois motifs nous vous invitons à
déclarer le projet de loi
irrecevable merci mon cher collègue la
parole est au
président contre la
motion monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues non non montez pas
monsieur parce que ça j'y vois rien les
auteurs de la motion tendant à opposer
l'exception
d'irrecevabilité soutiennent que ce
projet loi contient des dispositions
contraires au principes édictés par la
Constitution et j'ai entendu à l'instant
les raisons je vais tenter mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs
d'apaiser vos inquiétudes et de
démontrer pour quelle raison ce texte
est un progrès pour la démocratie locale
j'entends ainsi dire que le report des
élections cantonales et régionales
serait de nature à altérer la sincérité
du prochain scrutin sénatorial et que
celui-ci constituerait une atteinte au
principes constitutionnels il est vrai
qu'avec le report certains conseillers
généraux ça a été dit avant moi voteront
en septembre 2014 lors des élections
sénatoriales sans avoir vu leur mandat
renouveler en 2008 ils auront ainsi
participé à deux élections durant leur
mandat en 2008 et en 2014 pour autant il
ne semble pas que cela altérera la
sincérité du scrutin car les conseillers
municipaux de nos 36000 communes qui
sont une part essentielle du collège
électoral sénatorial auront été
entièrement Renou en mars 2014 comme l'a
indiqué le ministre soit sur 3000 grands
électeurs concernés conseillers généraux
et
régionaux sur 75000 grands électeurs
cela représente un peu plus de 3 % du
corps électoral je ne pense pas que 3 %
du corps électoral altère le résultat de
ce scrutin de plus selon deux
constitutionnalistes de Renant le report
le report d'
motivé par l'allègement du calendrier
électoral ne peut pas être utilisé pour
soulever
l'inconstitutionnalité d'une autre
élection cet avis est de nature à
rassurer en amont nos collègues de
l'opposition en réalité si parce qu'il
faut suivre le conseil constitutionnel
en réalité ce report est parfaitement
légitime sans cela l'année 2014 aurait
été particulièrement chargé en échéance
électorale avec la tenue de 5 élections
et de tours de
scrutin cet argument de la surcharge
électorale avait été jugé positivement
en 2007 mes chers collègues par le
président Sarkozi et le précédent
gouvernement lorsqu'il fut décidé de
prolonger les mandats des conseillers
municipaux et généraux jusqu'en 2008
c'était exactement le même argument et
en
1994 le mandat des conseillers généraux
fut prolongé d'un an combien de fois
avons-nous entendu dire que nos
concitoyens se désintéressaient de la
politique et notamment que les
cantonales et les régionales peut-être
encore plus ne les intéressait pas trop
qu'ell favorisait l'abstention et bien
pour mobiliser nos concitoyens lors de
ces élections il est indispensable de
modifier le calendrier électoral nous
n'allons pas convoquer les Français CIN
fois aux urnes en 2014 au risque de
démobiliser encore davantage nos
concitoyens je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel reconnaît et autorise la
possibilité de modifier la durée des
mandats électifs à une double condition
que cette cette modification soit
justifiée par des motifs d'intérêt
général et que cette modification est un
caractère exceptionnel et transitoire
cette double condition est bien remplie
dans le cadre de l'année 2014 et une
modification du calendrier électoral ne
pose pas de problème constitutionnels
par ailleurs la création d'un nouveau
type de scrutin pour les élections
cantonnables cantonal pardon semble vous
vous alarmer je vous rassure la mise en
place du scrutin binominal paritaire
répond aux dispositions de l'article 34
de la Constitution qui précide qui que
le législateur est compétent pour fixer
le régime des assemblées locales par
ailleurs depuis l'adoption de la loi
constitutionnelle du 8 juillet 99 la
parité politique est devenue un objectif
à valeur constitutionnelle dans le
Conseil s'est montré le gardien vigilant
elle est inscrite à l'article 1er de
notre Constitution depuis la révision
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2008 la
loi favorise l'égal accès des femmes et
des hommes aux mandats électoraux et aux
fonctions élective ainsi qu'au
responsabilités professionnell et social
le gouvernement s'est pas contenté de
défendre la parité il la réalise
concrètement le gouvernement de
Jean-Marc Héraud est le premier de
l'histoire à avoir la volonté politique
de répondre intégralement à cette
exigence de parité et bientôt au sein de
nos assemblées départemental il se
trouvera autant de femmes que d'hommes
voilà un progrès autant électoral que
sociétal qu'il nous faut accompagner en
instaurant le scrutin binominal
paritaire ce texte répond à l'exigence
de parité définie par la Constitution et
il marque un progrès avec des pratiques
politiques dont nous sommes chacun
responsabl comment pouvons-nous nous
satisfaire en 2013 que seulement 13 %
des conseillers généraux soient des
femmes je me permets également de citer
le 3e alinéa de l'article 72 de la
Constitution dans les conditions prévues
par la loi ces collectivités
s'administrent librement par des
conseils élus et dispose d'un pouvoir
réglementaire pour l'exercice de leurs
compétences en conséquence il me semble
que ces dispositions visant à modifier
le mode de scrutin des conseillers
généraux ne soulève aucun problème de
constitutionalité force de constater que
depuis plusieurs mois les collectivités
territoriales sont au cœur des débats de
notre haute assemblée je veux faire ici
référence évidemment au succès rencontré
par l'Organisation des États généraux de
la démocratie territoriale voulu par le
président du Sénat elle a permis de
redonner enfin la parole aux élus locaux
de libérer la parole des territoires et
dont nous avons tiré les conséquences il
est évident que nous partageons tous sur
chacun de ses bans un même intérêt pour
la question territoriale même si nous
défendons parfois des visions opposées
nous avons discuté et adopté la
proposition de loi déposée par notre
collègue éc d'oliger qui visait à
simplifier les normes s'imposant aux
collectivités territoriales c'était un
choix politique les 28 et 29 janvier
prochain
nous discuterons des deux propositions
de loi déposées conjointement par le
président sueur et la présidente
Jacqueline gourau la première créera une
haute autorité en charge du contrôle et
de la régulation des normes la seconde
concernera plus spécifiquement le statut
des élus locaux dans la foulée sera
examiné le projet de loi de la
décentralisation cet acte 3 que nous
appelons de nos vœux en proposant ces
différents textes le Sénat est à
l'écoute des représentants des
territoires notre institution est fidèle
à sa tradition et reste plus que jamais
la maison des collectivités
territoriales c'est dans ces
circonstances mes chers collègues que
nous examinons ce projet de loi que nous
propose le gouvernement qui est un texte
de raison c'est un texte ambitieux qui
ne fait pas de l'immobilisme une règle
immuable c'est un texte qui prend en
compte les réalités territoriales car
les territoires ont connu bien des
évolutions ces dernières années je crois
qu'il était temps d'adapter les les
modalités des conseillers départementaux
des conseillers municipaux et des
délégués communautaires à ces nouvelles
réalités géographiques et démographiques
le texte prévoit d'abaisser le seuil de
population permettant d'appliquer le
scrutin de liste proportionnel cet
abaissement du seuil va bien évidemment
dans le bon sens il permet de mettre fin
dans de nombreuses communes à
l'archaïsme du panachage il va favoriser
la mise en place d'équipe municipale
cohérente qui seront présenté
collectivement face au suffrage des
électeurs le panachage a un certain
charme c'est vrai mais je crois qu'il
n'est plus adapté à nos réalités
territoriales il n'est pas Simp pour
notre démocratie que dans des communes
les électeurs écartent certains
candidats en raison simplement d'un
contentieux familial ou personnel je ne
crois pas que ce seuil de 1000 habitants
soit figé le ministre l'a évoqué et il
nous appartiendra d'en fixer le juste
seuil autre réalité territoriale prise
en compte les différences démographiques
entre canton je crois qu'un descoupage
était nécessaire et légitime depuis 1801
c'est-à-dire depuis l'époque
napoléonienne 3 cantons sur 5 n'ont
connu aucune modification de leur
contour là aussi les temps ont changé
comme le rappelle l'exposé des motifs le
rapport entre le canton le plus peuplé
le canton le moins peuplé peut atteindre
1 pour 47 là encore une adaptation à nos
réalités s'imposé certes il faut
conserver de manière légitime nos
diversités territorial et géographique
car le monde rural a besoin d'élu de
proximité mais il était plus que temps
de procéder à ce redécoupage demandé par
le Conseil les cantons sont des
circonscriptions auxquelles sont
attachés les Français surtout dans les
territoires ruraux et il ne faut pas
priver les électeurs du lien qu'ils ont
avec leurs élus c'est la volonté du
texte de ce gouvernement avec ce fort
degré de proximité car le cancier
général et reste et demeure le maillon
essentiel et le lien entre les forces
vives d'un territoire les maires et
l'ensemble des associations s'appuie sur
lui parce qu'il fait le relais avec le
le département il ne faut pas éloigner
la démocratie représentative de la du
fait démocratique ce texte ne reproduit
pas l'erreur commise par le précédent
gouvernement en créant le conseiller
territorial en fusionnant les
conseillers généraux et les conseillers
régionaux on allait créer un être
hybride sans spécificité on allait créer
de grands territoires désincarné sans
cohérence et on allait supprimer un élit
territoriale sur deux est-ce que le
problème de notre démocratie c'est le
nombre d'élus non nous qui sommes
sénateurs nous savons très bien que ce
n'est pas le cas enfin pour
conclure enfin pour conclure j'ai lu
avec attention sur le site internet du
groupe UMP la ligne de conduite pour
2013 je cite nous ne laisserons pas la
gauche détruire les bases de notre pacte
républicain et de nos institutions et
bien ça tombe très bien parce que c'est
tout le contraire que nous voulons faire
il s'agit par ce texte de conforter
notre pacte républicain et de promouvoir
nos institutions en les modernisant nous
pourrons donc être d'accord mes chers
collègues en introduisant la parité dans
les assemblées départementales comme
nous l'avons fait à toutes les élections
nous mettons fin à une discrimination
qui n'a plus lieu d'être de nos jours le
scrutin binominal est innovant il peut
surprendre mais jusqu'à preuve du
contraire aucune autre formule n'a été
proposée qui allie à la fois la parité
et la
proximité en introduisant l'équité pour
les nouveaux contours de quanton
inchangé depuis de siècles nous nous
mettons en conformité avec le Conseil
constitutionnel chacun s'accorde pour
reconnaître que c'était une nécessité
d'ailleurs je crois que cela avait été
demandé au précédent gouvernement par le
conseil il faudra bien sûr tenir compte
tenir compte monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez évoqué des spécialités des
spécificité géographique démographique
et du nombre de communes qui est une
spécialité française c'est le maintien
de la proximité indispensable entre les
citoyens et leurs élus en introduisant
la clarté pour l'élection des délégués
communautaires nous modernisons notre
système et nous rapprochons l'échelon
intercommunal de nos administrés il en
était plus que temps en abaissant le
seuil pour le scrutin de list pour les
plus petites communes demandé par
beaucoup d'élus de tout bord et les
associations d'élus nous mettons de la
cohérence pour les élections municipales
en reportant d'un an les élections
cantonales et régionales nous rendons
mes chers collègues vous le savez un
fier service aux plus petites communes
qui était dans l'incapacité d'organiser
ces cinq élections et ces neu tours de
scrutin et nous clarifions la situation
politique en réalité cette motion de
procédure dont j'ai essayé de démontrer
qu'elle n'était pas fondée permet
simplement à l'opposition de manifester
son désaccord avec le le gouvernement ce
qui est légitime mais à notre avis ce
texte a deux qualités majeures sur
lequel nous pouvons tous nous retrouver
il répond aux exigences définies par la
Constitution et il est un progrès pour
la démocratie territoriale c'est ce qui
doit tous nous porter c'est pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons que je viens
de développer qui se fonde sur la
constitution s'imposant à chacun de nous
à tous les républicains que nous
voterons contre cette motion tendant
opposer l'exception d'reevabilités je
vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue j'ai
demandé l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur sur la motion
d'irrecevabilité monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission votre
commission des Lois n'a pas retenu cette
motion d'irrecevabilité pas plus
d'ailleurs que les autres motions de de
procédure mais en écoutant les uns et
les autres je pense que c'est bien
qu'elle ait été déposée
moi j'ai entendu les les arguments de
Monsieur Portelli et je lui donne acte
qu'il n'a pas manqué d'essayer
d'argumenter sur plusieurs points sur
lesquels il pensait qu'il y avait un
problème
constitutionnel je dois dire que j'ai
bien apprécié les les éléments qu'en éo
monsieur Guillaume notre collègue
Guillaume présenté à des charges je dois
dire que les uns et les autres sont
intér sans aucun n'entraîne l'adhésion
on est sur un texte qui effectivement
modifie les choses c'est pas choquant
que sur un texte comme celui-là certain
et souhaité aller le plus loin possible
retenons simplement que c'est un vrai
texte de rénovation de notre pratique au
niveau départemental et pendant tout le
débat que nous allons avoir retenons
cette idée nous sommes là sur un texte
qui va commettre un acte d'évolution
profonde de la manière dont les choses
vont se passer dans nos départements sur
nos pratiques sur la parité je crois que
c'est un point très positif donc
monsieur le Président la Commission ne
retient pas l'exception
d'reevabilité merci monsieur le
rapporteur avis du gouvernement monsieur
le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs je vais
répondre
précisément à Monsieur HUG Portelli qui
avancé un certain nombre d'arguments qui
méritent réponse vous avez avancé
monsieur Portelli que le projet de loi
du gouvernement pourrait constituer une
manœuvre en vue des élections
sénatoriales de septembre
2014 sans qu'il ait besoin de rappeler
président Guillaume l'a fait
avec beaucoup de Briot vous avez
raison sans qu'il soit besoin de
rappeler la part mineure que représente
aujourd'hui les conseillers généraux et
les conseillers régionaux au sein du
collège
sénatorial respectivement 2,6 % et 1,21
% des électeurs je souhaiterais tout
simplement vous citer les termes de la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
relative aux modifications des durées de
mandat puisque ce dernier a déjà eu
l'occasion de se prononcer sur ce sujet
à plusieurs reprises nous sommes à la
fois dans un débat politique mais nous
sommes dans un débat qui fait référence
à la loi fondamentale le conseil dans la
décision numéro
9028 déc du 6 décembre 1990 a admis la
prolongation d'un mandat locale au cours
en cours car celle-ci s'inscrivait dans
le cadre d'une réforme visant à
déboucher sur la concomitance du
renouvellement intégral tant des
conseils régionaux que des conseils
généraux et tel est ici je déjà
l'occasion de le dire notre objectif le
Conseil constitutionnel avait alors
conclu que les choix du Atur
s'inscrivait dans le cadre d'une réforme
dont la finalité n'était contraire à
aucun principe non plus qu'à aucune
règle de valeur constitutionnelle que
les modifications apportaient la durée
des mandats en cours revettaient un
caractère exceptionnel et transitoire et
que dans cette mesure elle
n'apparaissait contraire ni au droit de
suffrage garanti par l'article 3 de la
Constitution ni au principe de la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales par la suite saisi de la
loi du 16 février 2010 qui modifiait
également la durée des mandats des
conseillers régionaux et généraux chacun
son tour le Conseil a par ailleurs
considérer que la concomitance des
scrutins peut également trouver une
justification dans l'objectif de
favoriser une plus forte participation
du corps électoral à chacune de ces
consultations et c'est bien notre
objectif dans ce cadre le projet de loi
du gouvernement répond à la
jurisprudence pleinement du Conseil
constitutionnel en effet en prolongeant
d'une duré limité à un an j'ai
l'occasion de le dire mais je le répète
pour nos débats le mandat des
conseillers généraux élus en 2008 et des
Conseillers généraux élus en 2011 le
gouvernement ne porte pas une atteinte
au droit du suffrage et par ailleurs en
allongeant de 3 à 4 ans le mandat des
conseillers généraux élus en 2011 et de
4 à 5 ans le mandat des conseillers
régionaux élus en 2010 le projet de loi
se rapproche de la durée normale de ces
deux mandats de plus si le gouvernement
a reporté ces deux élections c'est pour
assurer que la participation électorale
ne soit pas découragée par la
multiplication des scrutins en 2014 et
que les assemblées local représente le
plus fidèlement les suffrages des
Français et la jur la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle que je viens de
rappeler sur ce point est indiscutable
enfin et je veux vous répondre très
précisément monsieur Portelli le
gouvernement n'ira pas dans la voie d'un
vote
plural d'une pondération de voix
proposée par la Commission consultative
présidée par Monsieur Lionel Jospin dans
une réforme possible du mandat
d'élection des sénateurs et je voulais
de ce point de vue-là être très clair
par rapport à l'interpellation qui a été
la vôtre le débat permet de préciser
aussi les choses donc ça ne peut pas
être un argument dans la discussion qui
est aujourd'hui la nôtre vous affirmez
aussi avons entendu au cours de cette
fin d'après-midi que le scrutin
binominal majoritaire serait contraire à
la Constitution au motif que la
représentation des électeurs ne peut pas
être partagée entre deux élus nous en
avons déjà beaucoup parlé mais il faut y
revenir c'est oublié que nombre de
scrutins je l'ai déjà dit se déroule au
scrutin de liste et que plusieurs élus
sont issus de la même circonscription
électorale et tel est notamment le cas
des conseillers régionaux élu au sein
d'une section départementale c'est
également ignoré que plusieurs
conseillers municipaux peuvent
représenter au sein du conseil municipal
d'une commune la même commune associée
la représentation par deux élus d'un
même territoire prévu par le scrutin
binominal n'est donc pas unique en droit
électoral français elle n'est en tout
état de cause en rien inconstitutionnel
enfin je rappelle que le mode de scrutin
proposé ne remet pas en cause le
principe du vote individuel des désélus
du canton au sein de l'assemblée
départementale vous l'avez d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière vous-même rappelé
à plusieurs reprises le gouvernement
entendu et je veux insister sur ce point
a entendu fixer dans la présente loi les
critères que le pouvoir réglementaire
devra respecter critères qui reprennent
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel et celle du Conseil
d'État et garantissant des cantons
respectant au mieux l'égalité devant le
suffrage la loi détermine également
l'effectif des conseils départementaux
comme pour tous les types d'élections
notamment l'article l337 pour les
conseils régionaux et l'article l125
pour les députés en Noure le Conseil
d'État auquel le le gouvernement a
demandé son avis sur les conditions d'un
remodelage n'a jamais mis en avant une
telle obligation juridique le
gouvernement a donc fait un pas en avant
en inscrivant dans la loi qui vous est
proposée des éléments qui jusqu'alors
ressortaient uniquement du pouvoir
réglementaire enfin je voudrais rappeler
que le canton n'est pas la seule
circonscription électorale qui fasse
l'objet d'une définition par le pouvoir
réglementaire les limites des communes
sont en effet modifiées par arrêté
préfectoral je vous répondre aussi sur
Paris propos de la loi PLM la loi a déjà
modifier la situation de Marseille de
façon indépendante des deux autres
villes en
1987 à l'initiative du président Godin
il y a donc un précédent le projet
gouvernemental tient compte des
évolution démographique propre à la
ville de Paris depuis
1982 le tableau des conseillers de Paris
n'avait pas été modifié depuis lors
alors même que la population parisienne
a considérablement évoluer en 30 ans
enfin la méthode de répartition des
effectifs des conseillers de Paris des
conseillers d'arrondissement est la même
rigoureusement la même rigoureusement
que celle utilisée en 1982 qui avait été
validée par le Conseil constitutionnel
mais si le président Godin a des
propositions à faire concernant le
scrutin de Marseille le gouvernement
tout à fait respectueux du président
Godin premier édil de la ville de
marseil nous sommes prêts à en discuter
mais vous ne pouvez pas utiliser cet
argument puisque déjà une des villes a
été modifiée par rapport aux deux autres
enfin comme did Guillaume je voudrais
vous rappeler que le gouvernement
poursuit par ce texte plusieurs
objectifs constitutionnels le premier de
ce l'objectif constitutionnel de parité
inscrit à l'article 1er de la
Constitution qui dispose que la loi
favorise l'égal accès des hommes et des
femmes au mandats électoraux et aux
fonctions électives et en érigeant un
objectif constitutionnel légal accès des
femmes et des hommes au responsabilité
élective et en institution en instituant
pardon une obligation pour les partis
politiques de contribuer à sa mise en
œuvre la révision constitutionnelle de
99 a ainsi permis l'élaboration d'un
édifice législatif qui favorise la
parité et nous le respectons si nous ne
l'avions pas respecté il aurait pu y
avoir parfaitement une motion procédure
rappelant que nous ne respections pas la
Constitution le Gouvernement propose
donc de parachever l'édifice législatif
afin que la parité soit une réalité
aussi dans la plus grande part des
assemblées élues j'ai déjà l'occasion de
le rappeler le second principe
constitutionnel que vise le texte est le
respect du principe d'égalité devant le
suffrage et la réforme du mode de
scrutin départemental conduira à revoir
profondément le contour des
circonscriptions électorales
départementales bien sûr je me
permettrai de rappeler ici quelques
exemples qui indiquent la nécessité de
réviser la carte cantonale actuelle dans
certains départements et nous l'avons
dit beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont rappelé
dans sur tous les bancs le rapport entre
le canton le plus peuplé et le canton le
moins peuplé atteint 1 pour 47 dans près
de la moitié des départements ce ratio
est supérieur 1 pour 10 et dans 18
départements il est supérieur 1 pour 20
malgré les changements démographiques
intervenus depuis la création des canton
en 1790 la carte cantonnale est restée
figée et ainsi ignorer les grands
mouvements de population qui ont marqué
la France des deux siècles et de tels
écarts même si nous devons être très
attentifs à ce qui a été dit sur la
représentation d'un certain nombre de
territoire ne sont plus acceptables au
regard du principe constitutionnel
d'égalité devant le suffrage le scrutin
binominal majoritaire permettra donc à
chaque département de se doter des
circonscriptions électoral respectant
l'égalité devant le suffrage sans
ignorer donc la spécificité d'un certain
nombre de territoires et nous pouvons
nous appuyer là sur la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle et administrative que
le gouvernement propose de codifier
parité respect de la démographie nous
sommes bien là dans des principes
constitutionnels que vous auriez pu
rappeler monsieur Portelli le 3oisème
principe que le texte soumet à votre
assemblée permet de mieux prendre en
compte le pluralisme des opinions
inscrit à l'article 4 de la Constitution
et je veux parler évidemment de ce que
nous proposons pour la démocratie
communale et intercommunale je termine
certains
euh d'entre vous ont évoqué en
commission ou ici euh en citant la
tradition républicaine de ne pas
modifier le mode de scrutin d'une
élection à moins d'un an avant les
élections au moins un an avant les
élections je voudrais sur ce point
rappeler également les termes très
clairs de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel daté du 20 juillet 1988
par laquelle ce dernier rappelle qu'il
n'existe pas de principes fondamental
reconnus par les lois de la République
interdisant vous avez raison la
modification des règles électorales dans
l'année précédent à scrutin en effet le
conseil a jugé que ce principe ne
résulte d'aucune disposition législative
antérieure à la Constitution de 1946 que
diverses lois antérieures ont au
contraire modifié les règles électoral
dans l'année précédent le scrutin
qu'ainsi la prohibition de telle
modification ne serait regardée comme
constituant un principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la République et
puis au fond en engageant la discussion
dès la fin de l'année dernière devant la
commission en l'ayant aujourd'hui en ce
début d'année 2013 nous respectons et
les principes constitutionnels et la
tradition mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en répondant point par point
au sénateur
Portelli je crois avoir fait la
démonstration comme l'a fait monsieur
Guillaume que ce texte est conforme à
notre loi fondamentale et c'est pour ces
raisons que le gouvernement monsieur le
Président est défvorable à la motion
merci Monsieur le Ministre est-ce qu'il
y a des explications de
vote je n'en vois pas je vais donc
consulter le Sénat sur motion de
d'irrecevabilité opposé par monsieur
Jean-Jacques yest et les membres du
groupe Union pour un mouvement populaire
et je suis saisi donc d'un scrutin
public par le groupe UMP je vais donc
demander à Mesdames et Messieurs les
secrétaires de procéder à ce
scrutin le scrutin est ouvert
ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos et j'invite
Mesdames et Messieurs les secrétaires à
procéder au
dépouillement
merci
mes chers collègues je vous donne donc
lecture des résultats du scrutin numéro
77 sur la motion tendant à opposer
l'exception d'irrecevabilité sur le
projet de loi relatif à l'élection des
conseillers nombre de votants 342 nombre
de suffrag exprimés 342 pour l'adoption
162 contre 180 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
cette
motion et nous en arrivons à la motion
tendante au renvoi en commission
motion donc déposée par monsieur
Jean-Jacques y et les membres de l'Union
pour un mouvement
populaire cette motion porte le numéro 1
rectifié et la parole est à Monsieur
Bruno rotaillot pour la
motion bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues je
voudrais au nom de mon groupe soutenir
cette motion de renvoi en commission
pour trois raisons pour trois bonnes
raisons la première raison c'est les
mauvaises conditions dans lesquelles ce
texte a été examiné je vais être rapide
puisque à gauche au centre à droite
chacun les a souligné ces mauvaises
conditions simplement je voudrais quand
même rappeler qu'il s'agit d'un texte
majeur puisque il va impacter soit pour
le calendrier soit pour le mode de
scrutin pratiquement l'ensemble de nos
élections territori municipal et
communautaire départemental et régional
c'est donc un texte majeur et pourtant
c'est un texte pour lequel la Conférence
des Présidents s'était réuni le 19
décembre dernier pour fixer l'ordre du
jour la date de passage pour fixer les
conditions les délais d'examen et le
même jour se réunissait notre excellente
commission des lois alors vous allez me
dire on a vu pire c'est vrai monsieur le
ministre on a vu pire avec votre
collègue madame Duflot sur un texte sur
la mobilisation foncière mais c'est pas
parce qu'on a vu pire et que c'est un
peu mieux en terme de délis qu'il faut
s'en satisfaire c'était une des
premières raisons que je voulais
souligner je pense que le respect de
cette assemblée comme de l'Assemblée
national exige aussi des conditions de
travail un peu plus longues et en tout
cas plus confortables pour aller au fond
des textes la deuxème raison c'est un
souci de cohérence souci de cohérence je
reprendrai d'ailleurs l'expression hier
soir qu'a utilisé notre collègue
François oketto quand il disait vous
avez mis la charue avant les bœf parce
qu'en fait qu'est-ce que et je parlerai
surtout du mode de scrutin qu'est-ce
qu'un mode de scrutin ça n'est pas une
fin en soi vous en conviendrez ça n'est
pas un objectif c'est une modalité qui
doit servir la mission assigner à la
collectivité pour laquelle le scrutin
est est prévu je voudrais m'expliquer je
crois que nous sommes
nombreux sur l'ensemble de ces V à
considérer que une des grandes
légitimités des départements c'est que
le département offre une sorte de
garantie pour la
ruralité parce que le département il est
capable d'articuler par sa taille
l'échelle de la proximité notamment avec
l'efficacité qu'on lui connaît pour
toutes ses politiques sociales et en
même temps toujours par son échelle par
sa taille il est capable de prévoir de
se projeter dans l'avenir d'articuler
donc le présent et l'avenir sur par
exemple les questions de désenclavement
et aut
et c'est là le problème et c'est là
qu'on fait le lien entre un mode de
scrutin le mode de scrutin que vous
proposez et les compétence d'une
collectivité on peut pas dire une des
forces des départements c'est la
ruralité et poser cet Act qui va
conduire comme conséquence à un
redécoupage qui va écraser qui va
amputer la représentation de la ruralité
plusieurs et au-delà des clivages
partisans l'ont redit mais je le redis
avec force vous vous avez choisi et pas
uniquement pour des raisons juridiques
vous avez fait le choix de la règle
arithmétique scrupuleuse vous avez fait
le choix uniquement de la règle
démographique plutôt que de faire le
choix de la territorialité de la
proximité de ce qui fait les bassins de
vie de ce qui fait que on a parfois en
France une conjonction entre des
périmètres administratifs des
circonscriptions mais en même temps des
périmètres affectifs des périmètres
d'identité et je pense que pour vouloir
régler une discrimination qui peut
exister pour pouvoir faire progresser
effectivement la parité vous créer une
autre discrimination territoriale
celle-là et j'ai entendu notre excellent
collègue monsieur mzard invoquer cette
idée de la fracture territoriale qu'on
connaît tous dans nos départements et il
faut y faire attention un objectif fut-
fut-il extrêmement loouable la parité ne
peut pas se faire au détriment d'autres
objectifs de la représentation
territoriale pour des élection
territoriale ou même pour la pluralité
puisque là quand un groupe gagnera un
canton il gagnera finalement de voix
donc de points de mesure de ce point de
vue-là de même je m'interroge vous avez
choisi j'y reviendrai un scrutin
majoritaire à quoi sert-il de vous de de
choisir ce scrutin majoritaire pour
maintenir le lien entre l'élu le
territoire et les électeurs si en même
temps vous
éloignez en redessinant la
circonscription électorale l'électeur
justement de de l'élu il y a une
contradiction que vous nous expliquerez
j'en suis certain mais je crois qu'il y
a encore beaucoup plus grave on passe
beaucoup de temps et on va passer
beaucoup de temps sur ce texte mais à
quoi sert de passer autant de temps avec
eu et c'est aussi un président du
conseil général qui vous le dit quand on
a le sentiment que et pas seulement
votre gouvernement mais d'autres
gouvernements et je l'ai suffisamment
dit ici et mes collègues de droite le
savent bien on a le sentiment du une fin
programmée des départements vous avez
raison monsieur le ministre laadf n'est
pas restée silencieuse nous avons reçu
la semaine dernière vous le savez bien
une lettre du président Claudie Lebreton
elle est très courageuse il tire un
signal d'alarme il se fait le relais je
cite de la colère des départements
ruraux et il dit le compte n'y est pas
et tous les présidents de conseil
gédéraux qui sont ici vous diront non le
compte n'y est pas nous avons bien vu en
fin d'année le débat sur la péréquation
et aujourd'hui les départements tous les
départements notamment ruraux sont
menacé d'asphyxie de morts lent alors à
quoi sert-il de passer du temps sur un
mode de scrutin si par ailleurs on se
pose pas avant la question du devenir de
la collectivité territoriale et si on ne
se pose pas la question aussi de savoir
si un mode de scrutin va servir le
fonctionnement le bon fonctionnement de
cette collectivité et permettez-moi de
vous dire que le choix du scrutin que
vous faites
va brouiller les cartes on a parlé tout
à l'heure de zizani mais le scrutin que
vous avez retenu qui est un scrutin
alors j'ai entendu original curieux j'ai
entendu aussi pitoresque je voudrais
ajouter moiussi bon petitête
fantaisiste c'est alors c'est un hommage
à la créativité au génie français
monsieur le ministre c'est un bel
hommage à la créativité française ça
c'est un point que que je voudrais que
je voudrais vous donner mais enfin de de
de candidats solidaires pour l'élection
de candidats solidaires pour le
contentieux et puis ensuite de candidats
solitaires dans l'exercice de leur
mandat de candidats solitaires on le
sait bien et c'est un mode de scrutin
vous vous êtes trompé tout à l'heure en
disant mais non il y a pas de problème
puisque un une un scrutin de liste
régional finalement c'est la même chose
mais non parce que sur un scrutin de
liste sur un scrutin de liste on choisit
l'assemblée délibérante c'est ce qui
assure la cohérence du choix et c'est ce
qui assure la pureté de la
représentativité par la procuration
entre l'électeur et puis l'élu et là
c'est très différent en fait votre choix
c'est un entre deux ni vraiment
majoritaire ni franchement proportionnel
c'est un entre de qui je trouve va bien
avec l'ire du temps l'aire de cette
époque et le positionnement sur bien des
points du du gouvernement mais ce que je
voudrais vous dire je ne sais pas s'il
est constitutionnel ou pas ce de SCR
ce que je sais c'est que en divisant la
notion de représentativité vous altérez
la représentativité et peut-être même la
dénaturez-vous on en reparlera
permettez-moi de vous dire que sur le
plan constitutionnel j'ai entendu les
réaction vous faisiez àx en collègue
tout à l'heure on peut considérer le
passé récent nous incite à penser que
les constitutionnalistes qui conseillent
le gouvernement peuvent parfois se
tromper c'est toujours une science qui
n'est pas une science exacte et il faut
y faire attention
la trème raison j'y viens je je pense je
parlais de souci de cohérence mais ce
que je crains c'est que derrière ce
souci de cohérence il y a un problème un
peu politique qui se cache
derrière et qu'on pourrait avoir c'est
un doute à faire à une forme de manœuvre
électorale vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure que vous souhaiteez que le débat
se passe dans la bonne humeur et moi
aussi et je voudrais en faire la preuve
quand on vous regarde quand je vous
regarde monsieur le ministre j'ai envie
de vous donner le bon Dieu sans
confession come on dit chez nous mais
quand je regarde le texte quand je
regarde le
texte quand je regarde le texte je me
dis que le diable parfois se cache dans
les détails et lorsque l'on met en
perspective ce qui va nous arriver
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a entendu pour
d'autres élections pour d'autres
élections Assemblée nationale européenne
sénatorial je vais en parler on peut
émettre des doutes on peut émettre des
doutes quels sont les doutes et sur quel
fondement les miens reposent--il pour
essayer de les objectiviser d'abord il y
a ce mécanisme du report de calendrier
qui a pour conséquence le gel d'une
partie plus ou moins significative du
corps électoral pour les sénatoriales 4
% à peu près en général mais sur
certains départements la Corse vous le
savez bien près de 10 % c'est
significatif et lorsque on s'applique
justement à transposer ses règles sur la
série numéro 2 des sénateur on voit que
ce gel qui paraît marginal aurait pu
changer les choses pour les résultats a
dans 11 départements et dans trois
départements on aurait eu mes chers
collègues une inversion complète des
résultats c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est un indice qui est troublant
d'autant plus troublant que un de nos
collègues qui n'est pas là Jean Vincent
placé mais il est parmi nous présents si
j'ose dire on y a fait allusion tout à
l'heure lors qui nous indiquait dans un
journal du dimanche que il fallait pas
se tracasser à 4 sièges près la gauche
conserverait la majorité du Sénat parce
qu'il y aurait une petite modification
du scrutin alors peut-être pas le vote
plural mais peut-être un un vote
proportionnel un peu augmenté pour des
départements par exemple qui élisent
aujourd'hui trois sénateurs quand on met
en ligne ces deux chosesl on est troublé
bon premère indice 2è indice alors
deuxème indice c'est le pompon c'est
l'abaissement c'est l'abaiss c'est
l'abaissement mes chers collègues du
seuil vous savez où on peut se présenter
au deè tour personne ne doute ici que le
chiffre 10 est un chiffre nombre d'or
chiffre rond il y a une portée un peu
magique le problème là aussi c'est que
lorsque on essaie de faire Louis negre
l'a fait hier les projections on se rend
bien compte que notamment pour les
dernières quantonal de
2011 on obtient 259 triangulaires et 121
une notamment triangulaire en présence
du Front national est-ce que vous me
direz si on s'est trompé dans nos
calculs ou non mais c'est un fait
pourquoi donc AB baisser ce seuil quel
est l'objectif d'intérêt général que
poursuit le gouvernement en faisant
cette proposition qui me rappelle une
phrase qui m'avait oui retenu dans un
article c'était plusieurs mois avant sa
mort je crois de François furé qui
devait s'appeler l'énigme française et
il disait c'était un c'est un avantage
sans prix que de disposer d'un alliier
objectif euh sous les traits d'un
adversaire radical avantage sans prix je
dirait qu'il ne faut pas en abuser autre
indice autre
indice le redécoupage le redécoupage
personne monsieur le ministre ne doute
ici qu'il fallait réduire les écarts ce
que nous contestons c'est que le
gouvernement veut s'octroyer un pouvoir
absolument discrétionnaire
pour faire les choses un peu quand même
à sa main en tout cas pour avoir une
liberté totale pour remodeler
radicalement la France des cantons et
cette liberté vous la trouvez à travers
deux dispositif le premier dispositif ce
mode de scrutin un peu imaginatif qui
vous permettra d'écraser de réduire de
diviser par deux et donc d'avoir le coup
de crayon le coup de ciseau beaucoup
beaucoup plus libre que s'il avait fallu
seulement faire des réajustements
purement démographiques par par rapport
à des frontières de quanton existantes
et et ça c'est quelque chose
d'important encore une fois le tenuel de
20 % vous pouvez euh dans une certaine
mesure l'élargir et je pense que la
règle du Conseil constitutionnel à
laquelle vous vous référez euh vous vous
référez de façon excessive à cette
contrainte s'agissant s'agissant d'une
assemblée territoriale dont l'objectif
est aussi contre contrairement à
l'Assemblée nationale et aux élections
législatives de ressembler de pardon
comment dirais-je d'imaginer et de
comment dirais- de représenter des
territoires voilà le deuxième dispositif
sur ce redécoupage qui me gêne beaucoup
plus c'est que vous souhaitez vous
affranchir des limites des
circonscriptions existantes je pense là
qu'il y a il peut y avoir en tout cas je
je le dis au conditionnel il peut y
avoir un problème en tout cas il peut y
avoir une disposition contestable du
point de vue constitutionnel du point de
vue juridique pourquoi pourquoi parce
que les deux je vais essayer de faire un
raisonnement court bref le plus clair
possible les deux derniers remodelage
législatif 86 et le dernier ont pris
soin et la loi l'a précisé de respecter
de leur dans leur intégrité les limites
des cantons bien comme si d'ailleurs le
Conseil constitutionnel pouvait juger en
se disant dès lors qu'il y a un nouveau
redécoupage il faut que au moins ce
nouveau redécoupage respecte les
redécoupages précédents d'autant plus
que les redécoupages précédents ont été
portés par une loi alors que le
redécoupage nouveau sera porté par un
décret fut-il en Conseil d'État donc il
me semble que là vous avez c'est vrai
une très grande liberté en vous
octroyant ce droit de franchir de
bousculer les frontières législatives je
pense qu'il pourrait y avoir une
faiblesse dans le raisonnement et dans
le texte en tout cas je souhaite que
vous me fassiez vous nous fassiez
plaisir et que vous nous fassiez aussi
mentir que vous acceptiez les
propositions que nous monquons pas de
vous faire par voie d'amendement il y en
a peut-être un amendement qui pourrait
montrer la bonne foi du gouvernement et
lever les doutes sur ces manœuvres
électorales que j'ai essayé de de
pressentir c'est d'accepter au moins
cette commission en plus du Conseil
d'État cette commission ad hoc qui
composéit de personnalités indépendant
dans une démocratie adulte permettrait
au moins de donner à vos futurs coups de
ciseau euh les traits si j'ose dire un
peu plus impartiaux que ceux que nous
craignons lorsque nous lisons l'ensemble
des dispositifs de votre texte merci de
votre attention mes chers
collègues merci monsieur rotillot la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel
contre la
motion monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues autant
monsieur le Président on a pu apprécier
l'argumentation de Monsieur Portelli
sans l'exception d' recevabilité même si
on ne la partageit pas autant je pense
que je pourrais m'arrêter là pour dire
que les propos de Monsieur rotillot
étaient complètement en dehors du sujet
d'ailleurs mon cher collègue d'ailleurs
mon cher collèg comment pouvez-vous
apprécier le travail de la commission
des lois dont vous ne faites pas partie
alors certes vous pouvez dire c'est
contre-rendu mais en fait c'est quand
même insuffisant donc je vais vous
donner quelques précisions et si votre
groupe vous a désigné pour faire cette
motion c'est bien parce qu'il n'y croit
pas parce que s'il y croyait il ne
manque pas d'éminents membres de l'UMP
de la commission des lois pour dire ici
ce qui s'est vraiment passé en
commission des lois alors disons-le
alors disons-le
monsieur delb notre rapporteur a été
désigné c'est vrai le 5 décembre le 19
la commission des lois s'est réunie
pendant 4 He pour entendre le rapporteur
la discussion générale les amend du
rapporteur le rapporteur a entendu un
certain nombre d'organisations dont vous
avez la liste dans le rapport si vous
l'avez lu monsieur retaillot ce dont je
doute il a également eu des
contributions écrites d'un certain
nombre d'autres organisations ensuite la
commission des lois S réun ce matin de
10h à 1h15 pour examiner 150 amendements
elle sera réunie ce soir de 7h30 à 9h30
pour examiner encore une centaine
d'amendements et elle se réunira demain
soir de 7h30 à 9h30 pour examiner les
derniers amendements je remarque
d'ailleurs je remarque d'ailleurs ce que
monsieur retaillot vous semblait ignorer
que parmi ces amendements plusieurs
plusieurs étaient des amendements
identiques d'autres des amendements de
conséquen d'amendements qui avaient été
rejetés et que donc finalement une vraie
discussion al en commission des lois et
je ne pense pas que le président yes me
contredira sur des amendements qui
vraiment posaient problème parce qu'ils
étaient nouveaux par rapport à ce qui
avait été examiné par la commission dans
sa première réunion et par rapport à
l'ensemble du texte et donc la
commission des lois a travaillé et a
approfondi sa discussion sur un certain
nombre d'amendements et d'ailleurs elle
Seira encore demain
alors bien entendu bien entendu rien
monsieur rataillot dans votre
intervention ne prouve que le travail de
la commission des lois a étit
insuffisant et qu'il faudrait retourner
en commission d'ailleurs je remarque
dans votre intervention d'un quart
d'heure qui était le temps imparti vous
avez évacué cette question en 3 minutes
exactement pas plus pour
ensuite nous faire nous présenter ce qui
aurait pu être une question préalable si
votre groupe l'avait présenté mais il ne
l'a pas fait pour quelle raison
d'ailleurs on se demande monsieur Bruno
sidau Président vous qui êtes paraî-il
le chef de fil du groupp à la matière
mais vous auriez pu dans une question
préalable aussi bien et peut-être mieux
que Monsieur retaillot développer tous
les arguments qu'il a développé tous les
arguments qu'il a développé et qu'on a
entendu et qu'on a entendu pendant 3h
sur la discussion générale le
département qui devait rester le
département qui était l'expression de la
ruralité
bon et que finalement paraî-il on
voulait supprimer les départements
j'avais cru comprendre que lorsque vous
avez fait voter par votre majorité le
conseiller territorial c'était plutôt là
qu'on pouvait trouver la désérance et la
et la la diminution et la fin des
départements et pas dans ce texte donc
tout ça c'était une question préalable
on a entendu parlant toutes la
discussion générale monsieur le ministre
a répondu très longuement au début de
cette soirée et donc je p que la
question était réglée mais elle ne
l'était pas ensuite pendant 7 minutes
exactement vous vous êtes livré à des
considérations totalement politicienne
il faut le dire il faut le dire
totalement politicienne vous d'ailleurs
dans le département à pourlogo l'emblème
des Vendé qui ont combattu la République
bel exemple bel exemple bel exemple et
donc et donc et donc et donc et donc et
donc et donc et donc des propos purement
politiciens des propos purement
politicien qui aurait dû qui aurait
dû qui aurait dû se retrouver si vous
voulez m'interrompre monsieur rotaillot
je vous le
permets si vous voulez m'interrompre
Monsieur rotillot Je c'est moi qui fait
qui décide monsieur le vouslez monsieur
ratillo voulez
répondre
oui je je voudrais faire un rappel au
règlement parce que on est amené ici
dans cette assemblée sur des textes qui
nous tiennent à cœur parce que on a les
uns les autres des responsabilités nous
sommes parlementaires nous avons des
exécutifs nous avons des responsabilités
locales et bien j'ai développé il y a
quelques instants vous savez quand vous
étiez dans l'opposition combien de
motions de renvoi ai-je écouté qui nous
permettait qui vous permettait de
combattre des textes et bien j'ai
développé la façon la plus claire
possible avec mes convictions les choses
Monsieur Michel je ne vous permettrai
pas de dire que les vendé1 et que la
Vendé est contre la République vous avez
fait une faute historique les Vendéens
ce sont les Vendéens à l'époque c'était
soulevé à cause d'une république
terroriste ils ont tous les cahiers de
doléance et je pourrais vous donner des
documents pour tous les CA doléance vous
verrez que les vendéin sur 1789 ont
soutenu les idéaux
1789 mais si j'ai cité François Furet et
je pourrais vous citer de nombreux
autres historiens vous verrez que cette
dérive de la terreur elle a tué des
dizaines de milliers de personnes dans
des conditions affreuses ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas lutter contre la République je
m'honore je m'honore d'être un élu d'un
département qui a donné en 1418 un des
départements qui a donné le plus de son
sang pour la République et je peux vous
assurer que nous sommes fiers à la fois
d'être vendéen mais surtout d'être
français et d'être républicain et
d'avoir pour emblème cher Monsieur
Michel le drapeau bleu blanc et rouge
qui est la synthèse française qui est
l'insythèse de toute l'histoire
française voilà c'est mon patrimoine
c'est notre patrimoine mais ne le
piétinez pas dans une discussion qui est
une discussion qui mérite autre chose
que ce type
d'invective merci mon cher collègue
Monsieur Michel si vous voulez bien
continuer repr je reprends donc je
reprends donc mon propos je voudrais
dire à Monsieur retaillot qu'en
transavversal Vendé plusieurs fois j'ai
été choqué par ce logo choqué par ce
logo qui est l'emblème des vandin et que
je partage et que je partage sur la
Révolution et la République pas votre
conception mais celle de clémentau cher
ministre de l'Intérieur la révolution ne
se découpe pas comme destranches de
saucissons on la prend en bloc en bloc
il n'y a pas de République terroriste il
y a la République point final et il y a
ceux qui l'ont combattu et qui étai les
vend je reprends mon propos
donc donc monsieur ro je comprends bien
que votre groupe qui avait beaucoup trop
de candidats dans la discussion générale
étant donné que vous êtes président de
conseil général a trouvé utile de vous
placer pour un quart d'heure dans une
motion de renvoi en commission voilà
mais exactement mais exactement mais
exactement donc je continue monsieur RET
vous n'avez donc
absolument rien prouvé en ce qui
concerne le sujet qui était le vôtre et
je pense donc mes chers collègues que
vous vous opposerez à cette motion de
renvoie en commission d'ailleurs vous
vous y opposez en quittant l'hémicycle
car vous êtes gêné par les propos de
votre collègue je vous remercie merci
avis de avis de la commission monsieur
le
rapporteur présid ent monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
j'étais comme vous transporté par la
justesse d'analyse de notre ami
Jean-Pierre Michel donc ça nous
éloignait un peu de de notre texte et et
en même temps que je l'écoutais je me
demandais de quoi nous devions parler le
renvoie en commission pour tous ceux qui
ont suivi la commission des lois c'est
Monsieur Béchu le renvoie en commission
monsieur Béchu tous les C
amendements vous avez évoqué le renvoi
en commission moi je
m'attendais à ce que vous soyez le
rapporteur et que ça va venir ça va
venir
ou mais ça va pas venir sur ce problème
là
immédiatement mais j'aurais bien aimé si
on avait un stock de renvoi en
commission qui nous aurait permis de
savoir ce ce que nous aurions pu nous
dire je dois dire que c'est vrai que
Monsieur reetillot non obstant ces
déclarations intéressante par ailleurs
il était d'ailleurs très pris par son
sujet j'ai vu comment à la tribune
il il s'autoconcentrrait pour nous dire
ce qu'il nous a dit très pertinent mais
qui n'avait rien à voir avec un renvoi
en commission et pourtant Monsieur yes
vous saviez nous nous attendions le
retour en commission
nous aimons débattre l'idée de nous
retrouver pendant une dizaine d'heur
était tout de même quelque chose d'assez
plaisant bon on a sacrifié ce plaisir
légitime pour un moment d'histoire de
France si j'ai bien compris à
interprétation variable d'accord mais à
un moment tout de même d'histoire de
France voilà pourquoi Monsieur le
Président je ne vois pas ce que la
Commission a à faire d'un non renvoi en
commission
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre quelques éléments monsieur rot
est parti je le regrette je rentrerai
pas évidemment dans ce débat passionnant
sur l'histoire d'abord très honnêtement
je crois que les délais d'examen ont été
satisfaisants d'abord notre texte
fondamental là aussi est respect
la procédure accélérée n'a pas été
déclarée la Commission a été saisie nous
débattons aujourd'hui nous commençons
d'ailleurs par le Sénat je l'ai indiqué
parce que le gouvernement souhaitait
commencer par la Haute Assemblée à
propos de textes qui sont très
directement liés à l'avenir des
territoires et chacun je crois veut
avancer puisque un choix a été fait
celui de l'abrogation du conseiller
territorial
personne d'entre vous n'a été pris par
surprise ça avait
été un choix du Sénat lui-même à travers
la proposition de loi présentée par
Madame borbeau voté par la majorité de
gauche le candidat François Hollande l'a
aussi proposé au cours de la campagne
aujourd'hui nous y sommes et à
partir du moment où il y a l'abrogation
du conseiller territorial nous en tirons
évidemment toute les conséquences je me
permets d'insister car je crois que
chacun dispose désormais de tous les
éléments nécessaires à la compréhension
du texte présenté par le gouvernement
qu'il y ait débat opposition c'est
normal l'étude d'impact qui accompagne
désormais chaque projet de loi se veut
la plus complète possible celle fournie
monsieur le rapporteur aurait pu le
rappeler comptant près de 50 pages
répond à cet objectif de lisibilité de
la loi et l'excellent rapport de Michel
Delbar a permis j'en suis convaincu de
clarifier les dernières interrogations
et je répète et je rappelle que j'ai
moi-même mené toute une série de
consultations pour éclairer bien avant
la fin de l'année l'ensemble des
formations politiques représentées au
parlement et enfin nous avons oui voulu
créer un dispositif original inventif je
prends les mots pour ce qu'ils sont
c'est-à-dire des compliments je rappelle
cependant que cet effort ination pour le
gouvernement a été facilité par le fait
que Michel André en avait fait la
proposition et que progressivement en
cherchant parce qu'il fallait chercher
la fois préserver le
département à instaurer la parité et à
garder ce lien de proximité nous ne
pouvions pas choisir la liste
départementale à la proportionnelle ten
cette proximité votre collègue tout à
l'heure ne m'a pas convaincu par un
système honnêtement qui alors là aurait
été totalement incompréhensible pour les
électeurs et à partir de cette base là
oui nous faisons une proposition qui je
crois est innovante et qui correspond à
ce qu'il faut faire j'ai déjà l'occasion
de répondre aux différents arguments sur
le binôme son efficacité dans la
campagne au moment de l'élection ou par
la suite je suis convaincu que la
campagne le projet qu'il porteront les
deux candidats recevront par ailleurs le
mandat des électeurs je voudrais
enfin dire à votre excellent collègue la
confusion qu'il fait d'abord sur le
scrutin législatif qui lui obéit à des
règles constitutionnelle la mise en
place d'une commission j'ai rappelé le
travail tout à fait impartial que
Monsieur Guena a fait avec le soutien de
Monsieur marlex comme quoi on peut être
élu
du tout à fait it impartial tout à fait
impartial c'est ce que je voulais
souligner comme quoi avec une avec une
commission indépendante on peut aussi
faire un travail tout à fait impartial
je rappelle qu'il y avait déjà à ce
moment-là par que c'était rappelé une
cinquantaine
d'exceptions à l'unité des cantons donc
déjà l'exception était relativement
importante dans la proposition qui nous
avait été faite enfin je voudrais
puisqueil s'agit pas de prolonger le
propos vous rappelez que pour ce qui
concerne la règle des 10 % j'entends
bien les mises en cause à propos de ce
changement moi je suis sur ces
questionsl tout à fait
ouvert d'abord souvent le scrutin
cantonal est localement moins politisé
qu'on le dit quand on voit les résultats
façon je crois que la question du Front
national se règle aussi dans le débat
public politique et donc ça concerne
ceux qui parfois s'en approche trop
dangereusement mais je suis ouvert sur
ces questionsl monsieur yest il
reviendra au cours du débat ce sont des
questions qu'on peut évidemment se poser
mais je voudrais quand même rappeler que
de
1969 à 2010 la règle c'était les 10
% donc le changement opéré en 2010 pour
des raisons sans doute qui n'était pas
politique euh à partir du moment où nous
abrogons le conseiller territorial nous
avons pensé humblement et puis vu votre
attachement au canton à ce rapport de
proximité que nous pouvions revenir
au-delà des modifications que nous
proposons au 10 % nous verrons bien dans
le débat si il faut évoluer ensemble sur
cette questionl mais je n'admets pas en
revanche je vous le dis très clairement
l'accusation qui nous est porté de
vouloir manipuler les choses par rapport
au Fond national de ce point de vue-là
sur le fond la majorité le gouvernement
n'ont aucune leçon à
recevoir
merci monsieur le ministre je rappelle
qu'il y a pas d'explication de vol c'est
pour un rappel au
règlement monsieur le Président je
souhaiterais demander une
suspension pour une réunion du groupe
s'il vous plaît combien de temps Madame
la 10 minutes la séance est donc
suspendue elle reprendra à 11h 23h40
pardon la séance est
suspendue
je faire le même
ve je suis pas compliqué moi je fais ce
que vous me dites de faire tout ça c'est
à cause de toi qu'est-ce que j'ai encore
c'est à cause de toi qu' avait eu le
conseiller
mes chers collègues la séance est
reprise madame trendley vous demandez la
parole je vous la
donne merci monsieur le Président je
souhaiterais m'adresser à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre
Michel je
voudrais lui dire que je suis
probablement autorisé à prendre la
parole étant membre de la commission des
lois et Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel vous
êtes coutumier du fait de provocation je
vous rappelle simplement les propos que
vous aviez tenu en commission des lois
et concernant l'Alsace et le droit local
il y a quelques semaines concernant les
propos que vous avez tenu tout à l'heure
et je regrette énormément que l'ensemble
de vos collègues est largement applaudi
à vos provocations qui avaient été
dirigé contre les
et bien concernant ces propos là
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel nous vous
demandons de les retirer retirer ces
propos et nous demandons vos excuses à
défaut je me verrai contrainte de
demander l'application de l'article 94
du
règlement merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur
Michel monsieur le Président je ne
pensais pas devoir choquer autant mes
collègues car je n'ai en aucun cas mis
en cause vandéin les Français qui
habitent le département de la Vendé et
qui sont français comme tout le monde
j'ai simplement dit madame la Présidente
que j'étais choqué que les élus de ce
département a choisi comme logo
l'emblème des vendéins qui avaient
combattu la République c'est tout c'est
un fait historique point
final madame trindely vous maintenez la
demande bien et ben écoutez je vais
suspendre la séance quelques instants
elle reprendra dans 10
minutes la séance est
suspendu
voilà pour l'examen cal vous pourrez la
revoir à tout moment sur notre site
publicsena.fr très bonne matinée à tous
sur notre
chaîne